AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THIS TORRENTIAL DOWNPOUR IN
NEW YORK COULD BE A BLESSING FOR
TONIGHT ANYWAY.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, VIOLENT
WRITERS, LOOTERS, ARSON IS
CAPITALIZING ON THE HORRIFIC
DEATH OF
GEORGE FLOYD ARE SICK AND
TWISTED INDIVIDUALS WHO SHOULD
BE LOCKED UP FOR A VERY LONG
TIME.
SO WHILE LEADERS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLES, THIS IS NOT AN
ISSUE AND ANYBODY THAT SEES THIS
VIDEO PRETTY MUCH IN AGREEMENT
THAT MAY BE THE EXCEPTION OF A
FEW KEYBOARD WARRIORS IN THEIR
UNDERWEAR, IN THEIR BASEMENTS
TALKING TO THEMSELVES, BUT FOR
THE MOST PART, UNANIMOUS
AGREEMENT ON THIS.
THAT IN OTHER WORDS, WE ALL
WATCH WITH OUR OWN EYES CAN
HAPPEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
PEOPLE RIGHTFULLY DEMAND JUSTICE
FOR GEORGE FLOYD.
BY THE WAY, THEY SEE JUSTICE AND
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE NOW HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY INJURED, SOME
KILLED IN THESE VIOLENT RIOTS
AND THE AFTERMATH THAT WE HAVE
BEEN WITNESSING THE LAST NUMBER
OF NIGHTS.
AND THEY WILL DEMAND FOR EXAMPLE
JUSTICE.
LOOK AT THE ST. LOUIS POLICE
CAPTAIN DAVID DAVID DORN AND OTH
SHOT DURING A VIOLENT PROTEST.
WILL THEY DEMAND FOR THE VEGAS
OFFICER IN CRITICAL CONDITION
SHOT IN THE BACK OF A HEAD BY A
RIDER OR THE THREE BUFFALO,
NEW YORK OFFICERS WHO WERE
INTENTIONALLY RAN OVER BY A
PERSON IN A CAR WHERE THE
THREE POLICE POLICE OFFICERS IN
DAVENPORT, IOWA, WHO WERE
AMBUSHED BY A RIDER WITH A GUN
OR THE TWO OFFICERS IN RICHMOND,
VIRGINIA, SHOT OR THE FEDERAL
PROTECTIVE SERVICES OFFICER WHO
WAS SHOT AND KILLED.
WE COULD GO ON AND ON.
ALL VIOLENCE IS UNACCEPTABLE.
LOOK AT NEW YORK CITY, ANARCHY
HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY BAD AND
OUT OF CONTROL.
ONE NYPD OFFICER WAS MOWED DOWN
BY A WRITER IN A CAR.
ANOTHER OFFICER BEATEN BY AN
ANGRY MOB.
30 OFFICERS BY THE NYPD HAVE
BEEN INJURED BY RIOTERS.
SOME OF THOSE INJURIES VERY
CRITICAL AND SERIOUS.
WE CANNOT FORGET ABOUT
WIDESPREAD LOOTING, DESTRUCTION,
ARSON, VIRUS, FIFTH AVENUE
LOOTED, MACY’S, HERALD SQUARE,
THE FLAGSHIP STORE, THANKSGIVING
DAY PARADE, "MIRACLE ON
34TH STREET" MACY’S, YEAH, NO
BUSINESS A FROM CRIMINALS.
THESE ARE CRIMINALS, NOT PART OF
A PEACEFUL PROTEST.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS ORGANIZED
CRIME MAY HAVE SOME OF THE
LOOTING, COMRADE
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO HAS BEEN
PRETENDING EVERYTHING IS FINE
AND DANDY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS SIDE-BY-SIDE
COMPARISON.
WE CALL IT de BLASIO VERSUS
REALITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> OVERALL IN A DAY WHERE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WERE OUT
EXPRESSING THEIR VIEWS,
EXPRESSING THEIR FRUSTRATION,
THEY ARE PAIN, THEY ARE ANGER,
THEIR DEEP DESIRE FOR CHANGE IN
LOCATIONS ALL OVER THE CITY,
OVERALL, WHAT WE SAW WAS
OVERWHELMINGLY PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATIONS.
WE WILL DEFINITELY ADDRESS SOME
OF THE THINGS WE SAW LATE IN THE
EVENING THAT WERE NOT PEACEFUL
AND NOT ACCEPTABLE, BUT YOU TALK
ABOUT THE REALITY OF THE FULL
DAY.
WE SAW MORE AND MORE PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATORS COMING TO THE
FLOOR.
>> Sean: HE HAS TO BE AMONG
THE DUMBEST POLITICIANS.
AND THAT’S SAYING SOMETHING IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD.
EVEN YESTERDAY AFTER DAYS OF
RIOTS, BEATS DOWNS, LOOTING,
COMRADE de BLASIO REMINISCING
ABOUT HIS FAVORITE SONG,
JOHN LENNON’S "IMAGINE."
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I UNDERSTAND AND I DON’T MEAN
TO MAKE LIGHT OF THIS BUT I’M
REMINDED OF THE SONG "IMAGINE"
BY JOHN LENNON.
I PLAYED THAT AT MY
INAUGURATION.
EVERYONE WHO HEARS THAT SONG AND
FULLNESS THINKS ABOUT A WORLD
WHERE PEOPLE GOT ALONG
DIFFERENTLY.
THINK ABOUT A WORLD WE DIDN’T
LIVE WITH A LOT OF THE
RESTRICTIONS THAT WE LIVE WITH
NOW.
BUT WE ARE NOT THERE YET.
WE ARE MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS.
>> Sean: HE CAN REMINISCE ALL
HE WANTS.
HIS POLICE HE STILL MIGHT POLICE
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN WARNING HIM
FOR DAYS ON AND ARE UNDER
ATTACK.
AND THANKS TO NEW YORK ABSOLUTE
INSANE REFORM AND ANDREW CUOMO
SIGNS IT.
AS SOON AS YOU GET ARRESTED, NO
BAIL WHATSOEVER.
SO POLICE ARE FORCED TO DEAL
WITH THE SAME CRIMINALS NIGHT
AFTER NIGHT AFTER NIGHT.
IN JANUARY THERE WAS A GUY THAT
ROBBED FOUR DIFFERENT BANKS,
RELEASED UNDER JAIL UNDER THIS
POLICY JUST TO GO OUT AND ROB
ANOTHER ONE.
ARRESTED AGAIN, GO RUB ANOTHER
ONE.
THAT IS HOW INSANE THAT IS.
AND LIKELY WE ARE SEEING THE
SAME THING WITH THE LOOTERS,
RIOTERS AND THE ARSONISTS.
HOWEVER NEW YORK’S ATTORNEY
ARRESTED FOR THROWING THAT
MOLOTOV COCKTAIL INTO A POLICE
CAR, HE WAS FORCED TO FORCE
BAIL.
LUCKY FOR HER FORMER INTEL
OFFICIAL HELP HOST THE BILL FOR
HER.
WOW AND MEANWHILE ACCORDING TO A
BRAND-NEW FOXNews.com REPORTS,
A "BLACK LIVES MATTER"
FOUNDATION APPARENTLY PREPARING
FOR A "WAR ON POLICE."
THEY ARE REPORTING TRAINING A
BUNCH OF ARMED INDIVIDUALS TO
PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITY FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY ARE CALLING THEM SELF PEACE
OFFICERS.
KEEP IN MIND, OKAY,
"BLACK LIVES MATTER," THEY HAVE
A MISSION.
ERADICATE WHITE SUPREMACY.
NO AMERICAN, NO GOOD AMERICAN IS
BIGOTED OR RACIST.
OKAY?
YOU HAVE TO PROTECT EVERY
AMERICANS RIGHTS.
I AGREE WITH THAT TOO, TO STAND
AGAINST RACISM AND BIGOTRY BUT
APPARENTLY NOW THEY ARE WILLING
TO DO WHAT, ARMED MILITIA?
HOW DO WE INTERPRET THAT?
THEY WANT TO PUSH THE POLICE OUT
OF NEIGHBORHOODS.